what do you want to do buddy  who the [ __ ] wants to do that dog what's  your ethnicity y'all the whole back of  the room guy is stuck you're mexican oh  this guy man forgot where he came from  literally what did you actually do  tsa you just love snitching on everybody  huh that's your whole [ __ ] you just  love [ __ ] up brown people one way or  the other  you are a unique individual though  even a relationship  what is your girl's ethnicity  ah there it is you had enough of this  [ __ ] huh  i was waiting for it to make sense and  now it makes sense you've been trying to  break up with this fish for three years  can't do it now she's gonna move her  whole ass family out  now anytime she's nagging him he can  just flash his badge in her face and be  like really who doesn't take out the  trash enough i think i'd take out the  trash for a living actually you think  about it